ciao ragazzi bentornati non ho puntata
di cucina buttata lo so vi chiedo
perdono a nome mio e di tutte le altre
persone che gravitano attorno a questo
format ma abbiamo un problema huston è
chiaro siamo nella merda non abbiamo una
cucina quindi stiamo in questo momento
cucinando il salone un sacco di commenti
che stiamo leggendo ce lo dicono e c'era
ribadiscono quanto faccia schifo questo
set
sappiate una cosa devono promessa stiamo
lavorando per avere una cucina dignitosa
e in realtà stiamo lavorando per avere
qualcosa di più detto ciò evito di
parlare troppo prima con una macumba ci
porterà a stare sotto i ponti a fare
cucina su bidone
partiamo subito col video di oggi
comunque sarebbe da fare bellissimo
subito cucinare la tua dei nin routine
come mai fatto un piatto di pasta quel
ruolo come diversi tipi se ti miti sui
fornelli seppure più buono considerando
che per quella carne e messaggio di oggi
è se sei una pippa cucinare punta sulla
presentazione e se sei una diva sulla
presentazione punta a ordinare delivery
il cui si era subito noi potrebbe essere
formata molto forte oggi
fondamentalmente facciamo una cosa tipo
sull'importanza della cornice del quadro
quando il quadro non c'è
facciamo ricami di tovaglioli che anche
il motivo di questo meraviglioso sfondo
che molto probabilmente creerà degli
attacchi foto epilettici e che ci sta
guardando le posso dire comunque non è
importante la cornice di un quadro ma il
quadro è in realtà un sacco di persone
guardano come ti vesti e non chi sei
era una stronzata però lo so nel mondo
aveva così andiamo solamente con
l'immagine a quello che state facendo
nel modo giusto che vuol dire che sono
vestito male di cosa avremmo bisogno
oggi prima di tutto di fazzoletti di
carta ed i tovaglioli sì lo so io sono
un nobile quindi li uso anche come
fazzoletti i fogli di carta igienica non
è che siano proprio meravigliosi come
colore
me ne rendo conto avremmo potuto fare di
meglio assolutamente sì andata no
abbiamo questo questo grigino che
secondo me va un po bene con tutto anche
per quando non ci sarà il più
questi sono non so se avete presente se
qualche vostra non le avevo i vostri
genitori
anche voi avete ereditati da qualche
antico re fondamentalmente sono
portatovaglioli maioli sono dei per i
tovaglioli la cosa più difficile
vi giuro più difficile da trovare nella
storia delle cose difficili da trovare
ci abbiamo messo giorni in nessun posto
li vendono nemmeno nei posti che si
occupano di cucina
nemmeno i cinesi ce l'avevano danko
frodo anelli del potere quello che ti
rende invisibile quello che ti rende
bellissimo quello che studente come
enrico ha infine avremo bisogno di un
piatto delle forchette si era una
battuta un po di sé proprio sbagliato
anzi sempre lui subito con il primissimo
o ricami dobbiamo prendere il fazzoletto
pastazzo letto tovagliolo e passarlo
dentro sembra il cappello parlante
a me sembra altro non mi sembrano
sempre di maiali amico detto una
montagna ripieghiamo in dentro le
estremità inseriamo le nostre posate
meravigliose dentro questo è il più
carino e adagiandolo sul tavolo sul
piatto inseriremo quello che io chiamo
il tocco finale segreto carc un fiore to
immagine di arriva una cosa così i toni
il fiore scopri che è di plastica
potresti usare un fiore vero bellissimo
una volta sono andato in un ristorante
dove nel cestino del pane c'è una lumaca
senza guscio
quindi se volete anche voi perdere una
stella michelin fate così questo qui
credo che sia stato il nostro canto del
cigno
nel senso che non andremo a migliorare
prossima composizione prendete il vostro
tovagliolo a questo punto prendete il
menu lo mettete appena sotto
perfettamente centrale 12 prendete il
piatto sembra in kimono pieghiamo
internamente anche questo pirlo
internamente infine da un piccolo
fiocchettino tac questo qui è proprio
quando vuoi tu anche gatti tanto andiamo
avanti prossima semplicissimo lo
spieghiamo come si dice in diagonale
pensiamo a raja ma lei bello circostanza
non mi torna massimo sbagliata loro
togliamo dalla punta
ti chiamo yes infiliamo l'anello eppure
a leggere sul piatto forse bisognerebbe
utilizzare un tovagliolo un pochino più
morbido abbastanza rigido e questo è
tosto allora lo pieghiamo per metà dal
basso verso l'alto lo ripaghiamo lo
pieghi un'altra volta
a me sembrano sacca porta sto coso e lo
spieghiamo in questo modo diamo sopra
questi qui internamente giriamo così a
questo punto dovremmo sbucciarla 12 e
sono le vele di sydney 20 il bicchiere
un calice si sa campo ha il suo fascino
forse bisogna farlo con dei bei
tovaglioli grossi di carta 5 prendiamo
il tovagliolo lo paghiamo per un terzo
l'altro terzo lo chiudiamo dito qua
pieghiamo in giù dito qui pieghiamo in
giù rigiriamo 1 2 e 3 1 2 e 3
a questo punto è cosa succederà che
avremmo creato uno mi importa un
delizioso ci tengono a ribadire
delizioso segnaposto
allora è un segno rosso benissimo da
roberto dico sì perché in realtà è un
clero che si esibisce alla mio papà
edilizio sono ragazzi siete milioni
capire card hai tirato fuori qualche
perla 32 consecutivi il prossimo è molto
semplice ci può fare ciò comunque
attaccata a bellissimo dai semplice non
è derivata dalla tac tac tac tra il
giallo di un ventaglio adulti sotto val
di lui era mordete di nascosto degli
altri ospiti un anello viola funziona e
se volete mettere la forchetta questo
qui semplice e veloce a prova di tordo
appresso come equa a parte gli scherzi
ci sta bene di nuovo lui anche se li di
copie bellissimo puri che sono tutte c'è
un piatto non sotto loro c'è una tavola
sotto tac c'è marco senza negare senza
artistico di marco è un qualcosa di
imbarazzante a questo quello che
mistrello non vi facciamo vedere che
come abbiamo fatto vi prego non dite vi
piace perché è imbarazzante 21 21 e
molto più carino se a sto punto allora è
così
così in azzurro che è un pipistrello con
la cintura a prendiamo il tovagliolo lo
rigiriamo così lo togliamo così fusi
addirittura qui so che ho la vostra
attenzione
apriamo qui apriamo qui stringiamo
prendiamo il cosino giallo e lo apriamo
cosa può sembrare che cosa la morte è
vero era tipo da martin capoccia
inserire io mi sto facendo costretto
[ __ ] ma se ne prendi belli ricamati
di fatti a mano ma dove genere sul
soggetto piuttosto sconsolato clicchiamo
qui e siamo a piegarlo e poi qui
addirittura in finiamo dentro lo metti
in freezer abbassi qua no è una candela
teoricamente la vita cambierà nel nuovo
il prossimo
io intanto sta andando avanti impiego a
metà piego qui rigiro 12
a questo punto semplice semplice ma
comunque di gran classe
l'impianto nostra tesi grazie mamma mia
male queste cose abbiamo preso
naturalmente dai instagram da youtube
qua sotto vi lasciamo pure i link
guardatevi serio creativo dopo i fagioli
delle regole per fare io bello ci piace
andiamo avanti
me ne faccio vedere uno che se viene
piangete tac battono tutti con questa
piega ma poi mi prendono tutte una piega
diversa la tac tac tac tac
gira gira gira gira gira gira gira gira
gira gira gira gira infiliamo
il titolo mostra del cardinale mattei
apriamo e dovremmo avere vedete una
specie di rosellina e la mettiamo
anche la caritas è carina
sembra un animale chissà se quel
cardinale alto potevo diventare una
splendida roma piego ripiego
a questo punto incominciamo a sfogliare
il primo il secondo lo facciamo entrare
tac di nuovo lo rigiro 12 e mi ritroverò
sul piatto minchia bellissimo
all'interno del quale posso mettere
cucchiaio e forchetta e il coltello è
totalmente storto
molto carino molto elegante e molto
semplice questo fiore al 4 sfiora ma non
raggiunge credo che sia reato il momento
dopo aver sviluppato le mie skill di
creare il mio tovagliolo che si sfiderà
contro quelli gianmarco è quello di
ricotti l'aveva dovrà
se si può al massimo implementare con un
coltello un cucchiaio una forchetta
scegliete la vostra posata il coltello
perché sono molto affilato ok il cus
ma non troppo la forchetta grazie mille
e scegliete al massimo uno di questi
avremo attesta a cinque minuti gli altri
non posso vedere che cosa si fa no mi
piacerebbe qua quindi a turni via allora
allora io questo qui faccio così faccio
così così non so cosa che credo che
questa che sia una mossa interessante da
fare
faccio così così così
sa che sta diventando incidentato non
avrò così ampio così si apre così che ok
e questo lo riapro sotto nella
realizzazione di più
ok no mostruoso nel mostruoso e
mostruoso perché questo è tutto diverso
qui viene mi quando mi manca un minuto
questo il filo qui io non so cosa ho
fatto minimamente ma questo qui è il mio
forse se lo spiego così è più carino no
però vedo che era in fuori non costringo
un po di più qui
ecco è meglio così ragazzi questi due
definizioni qua dentro
questo qui è un metodo principessa
[Musica]
io non mi collega il cervello mazza
sembra pietre le fantaghirò sto coso
basta questo credo perché quasi per
forza così potevo fare non sapere quanti
il prossimo proviamo un classico no
alla fine ragazzi
[Applauso]
a guardare intanto c'è un cazzo da
guardare quanto manca un'idea va bene è
andata così
mamma mia ragazzi allora si sta
avvenendo benissimo
mettiamo un po di paura
devo giocare forse sulla semplicità è
l'unica cosa che può salvarmi perché gli
avversari sono molto forti
semplice la semplicità vince sempre oggi
questa funziona forse quando manca
mammamia marito amara
e terribile cazzo
all
non pensavo ragazzi non so se sono
tagliato comunque se ti è piaciuto
questo video condividetelo fatelo vedere
i nostri amici iscrivetevi metteteci un
bel pollice su per il ma adesso è il
momento della votazione fateci sapere
quale preferite
fra i nostri tre trova trovajoli 3
maioli siamo pronti bye bye il mio ti
sei ispirato a qualcosa che hai visto no
mi sono ispirato al cigno davvero
presente quando fai il cigno quello di
[ __ ] camini carta procedimento xl
uguale
poi da lì da gianmarco il mio papà
e vigato infilato mi dispiace dover e
sincero molto elegante e semplice in
quanto a semplicità questo il mio dentro
in realtà è strutturato finale
caro pochi secondi ho piegato bisogno di
cross del tempo guarda che stavi per
fare una cosa nostra ci interessano
facendo qualcosa di interessante ma
prima si inquadra rara ma possibilissimi
scusa ma c'è un ispirato al cigno io
infatti il vostro preferito siete team
con l'air motivi già barco ottime
ricotta pensando di gran cucchiaio più
lungo
[Risate]
siamo arrivati alla fine grazie mille
per aver seguito ciao ciao ci vediamo
giovedì prossimo
voglia di stare a dieta ma credo che tu
te ne sa libero